Tu vois Romain je me disais l'autre jour
Il y a des trucs on les a sous le nez a longueur de journée
Et on se rend même pas compte à quel point il sont important
Romain : Ah mais c'est gentil mais je suis habitué à travailler dans l'ombre
Non mais je...
...je parlais de crottes de nez là
Vous en avez tous déjà roulé une entre vos doigts
Mais est ce que vous vous êtes seulement demandé d'où elles venaient vraiment et à quoi elles servaient
Au mieux vous les méprisés au pire vous les détestées
Depuis qu'elle vous ont gachés un rendez-vous en faisant une appartition imprévue
Et pourtant vos crottes de nez elles vous veulent du bien
Si
Si si
Ah si si je vous jure
Bon laissez moi vous expliquer
Je ne vous apprend rien l'air qu l'on respire n'est pas propre
Eh bien notre corps déploie des trésors d'ingéniosité
Pour le nettoyer avant qu'il n'atteigne nos précieux poumons
Ça se fais tout le long des voies respiratoires mais ça commence dans le nez qui humidifie qui réchauffe et surtout qui dépoussière l'air qu'on inspire
Comment ?
Grâce a deux dispositifs plus ou moins sofistiqués
Les poils du nez d'abord
Qui jouent le rôle d'un filtre chargé d'empêchés les particules d'entrer
Bonne soirée
Hop hop hop
Pas de pollen pas de poussière ça dégage
Et puis il y a le mucus
Le mucus c'est un liquide gluant
Qui est sécréter par la muqueuse des fosses nasales
Qui est chargé d'emprisonner les impuretés
Et de les gardées bien au chaud
Un peu comme...
Un peu comme du papier tue mouches en fait
Le mucus détruit une partie des cochonneries filtrées par le nez
Mais les gros morceaux restent coincés dans les narines
Ensuite ils séchent
Et ils deviennent ce qu'on appelle : les crottes de nez
En temps normal le mucus est transparent
Mais il peut prendre la couleur des particules qu'il absorbe
Et en cas d'infection des globules blancs que l'on appelle neutrophiles
S'attaquent aux germes grâce a des enzymes qui contiennent du fer
Et c'est ce fer qui est contenu dans les déchets qui sont ensuite rejeter
Qui donne cette couleur verte traditionnellement associé aux crottes de nez et à la morve
"She slime me "
Ah tiens au passage
La morve c'est le nom d'une maladie infectieuse qui touche les chevaux et les ânes
Elle est transmissible à l'homme mais elle a quasiment disparue
Et c'est tant mieux car elle est mortelle
Vous voyez qu'on est loin des petits cacas de nez
Non là le vrai nom c'est le mucus
Ça va Romain t'est tout pale
Romain: Euh non non ça va pas trop là
Ah c'est l'histoire des chevaux la morve tout ça ?
Romain: Non c'est juste
Les crottes de nez il faut pas trop en manger c'est ça ?
Ah ok
J'imagine que Romain n'est pas le seul a être engoissé à ce sujet
Alors on va faire un petit point culinaire
Sachez que le mucus est composé de 95 à 97% d'eau
Le reste étant des ions comme le sodium par exemple
C'est pour ça que c'est salé
Il contient aussi des substances inoffensives comme des protéines ou des lipides
Et en réalité on en avale à longueur de journée sans s'en rendre compte
Parce que les fosses nasales en produisent jusqu'à 1 Litre par jour
Qui coule dans l'arrière gorge avant de finir dans l'estomac
Et d'être digéré comme un vulgère entremet
Donc le mucus en soi n'est pas toxique
Alors si vous avez un petit creux
Et que vous êtes dans un bar qui n'offre pas les cacahuètes
Vous pouvez y aller
D'autant plus que...
D'autant plus qu'en réalité du mucus plein de poussière vous en avaler aussi un autre
Celui qui vient d'en bas
Et oui parce que du nez au fin fond de vos bronches les paroies de votre appareil respiratoire sont tapissées par deux types de cellule
Les cellules à mucus
Et d'autres qu'on appelle à cellules à cils vibratiles
Bon alors, si vos cellules ont des cils vibratiles c'est pas pour faire sexy
C'est pour fabriquer un véritable tapis roulant pour le mucus
Je m'explique
Les cellules à cils vibratiles ça ressemble à ça
Bon...
Si l'idée d'avoir des anémones de mer dans la trachée ça vous traumatise
On va essayer autre chose
Imaginez une tribune dans un stade
Dans laquelle tout le monde porte ce bonnet ridicule
Maintenant imaginé que tout ce petit monde fais la hola
Ben voilà vous avez à peu près le mouvement de vos cellules
Alors vous aller me demander mais à quoi ça sert
Romain: Mais à quoi ça sert ?
OOOHHH !!!!
Ça suffit Romain maintenant !
Eh bien ce mouvement ininteromput forme un véritable escalator à mucus
Qui raccompagne les sécrétions et les particules indésirables quelle contiennent jusqu'à l'arrière gorge
Ou elles sont avalées
Ou crachées c'est comme on aime
Attention la fumée de cigarette en plus de contenir des substances cancérigènes
C'est pas l'ami de vos cellules vibratiles
A court termes elles les paralyses
Et à long termes elles les tuent
Du coup les sécrétions ont de plus en plus de mal à rejoindre la sortie et elles stagnes dans la trachée
Et ce qui stagne ça a tendances à s'infecter
C'est pour ça que les fumeurs toussent et ils crachent des trucs sales
Ou les avalent
C'est comme on aime
Sachez aussi qu'en cas de maladie
Votre corps malin comme il est il se rend bien compte qu'il va avoir un maximum de germes à évacuer
Donc il augmente ça production de mucus
Euh les mecs il faut venir m'aider là ils sont revenus avec leurs potes
C'est pour ça que dans ces cas là ont a le nez qui coule et la toux grasse
Voila j'espère que vous êtes réconciliés avec vos crottes de nez
Vous voyez bien qu'elles sont sympas
Oh et dernière choses vos poils du nez ils sont cool aussi vous avez vus
Alors
Si vraiment vous avez des dreadlocks qui vous sortent des naseaux
Coupez les à ras
Mais n'aller pas couper ce qui sont à l'intérieur
Vous en avez besoin
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
Vous pouvez me poser vos questions sur la santé et le corps humain dans les commentaires
N'oublier pas de vous abonner
Et à la semaine prochaine
Comme d'hab